my iPad is one of my best friends we
cuddle together on the couch when I
watch Netflix it comes to bed with me
and sleeps right beside me every night
and then we spend the morning commute
together everything is so perfect until
I have to do work when it comes to
getting stuff done it is straight for
the laptop I'm just way more productive
on here with a real keyboard and real
multitasking features the tablets
they're not taking this lying down the
new trend in tablets is to make them
more work-friendly with physical
keyboard and better productivity
software the new Galaxy Tab even has a
12 inch screen to make it similar size
to a laptop but can any of these
actually make working on a tablet and
enjoyable experience
well for the last week I completely
ditched my laptop and try four of these
tablets to see how they stack up the
first one that brand new Samsung Galaxy
Note pro 750 dollar tablet has a huge
high-resolution 12 point 2 inch screen
comes with a stylus and you can buy a
keyboard cover for $99 it runs Android
but Samsung has added a lot of its own
features then I used to Windows 8.1
tablets because Microsoft confusingly
still has two Windows operating systems
the Nokia Lumia 2520 has a 10.1 inch
screen and runs Windows RT which cannot
run older Windows programs it costs 399
dollars but the keyboard which has a
battery inside costs 150 dollars more
then there is the surface pro which runs
the full version of Windows 8.1 the
tablet starts at $900 and the keyboard
with real keys cost another 130 dollars
and it currently about the tablet use
the most the iPad the $499 iPad air
doesn't have a keyboard made especially
for it so I paired it with a $99
Logitech ultrathin keyboard cover then
it was business kind
and compared all the tablets on four
pieces of criteria multitasking app
selection text input and battery life
when it comes to working multiple
programs at once in this case email
Twitter and a browser the Galaxy Note
pro actually has some good tricks some
apps can be minimized and moved around
and you can just draw a box where you
want to open a new app it sure beats the
iPad which has no way of putting two
apps next to each other but I still
found both Windows tablets to be the
best on managing apps it did the best
job of allowing me to put apps
side-by-side easily get to other open
apps and all those handy windows
keyboard tricks still work and both the
nokia and the surface have trackpad if
you don't want to reach up and touch the
screen typing tag it was a tie for the
best keyboard I was able to type
eighty-two words per minute on the
Samsung keyboard and on the surface type
cover that's that I enjoyed typing more
on the surface keyboard it's just made
better and feels nicer I typed 80 words
per minute on the nokia keyboard and
then 72 on the iPad keyboard still both
are much faster than I can type on
screen I should also mention that
there's a reason they call laptops
laptops none of these tablets like
sitting on my lap and even if you can
multitask and type fast it's not going
to matter if you have the apps you need
if you just use a browser and email then
these are all pretty evenly matched and
each of them also comes with a suite of
productivity software Samsung even
teamed up with a Korean company named
hand comb to preload software that looks
exactly like Microsoft Office hmm looks
pretty pretty similar Apple also
includes I work with any new iPad
purchase however most businesses still
use Windows programs including Word
Excel and PowerPoint that's why the
surface pro comes the closest to being a
great laptop replacement well until you
realize that the battery life seriously
takes a hit the iPad Galaxy Note pro and
Nokia were able to stream video for over
eight hours but the
purpose could only keep up for five and
a half hours is it the weekend yet as we
might have expected the Windows tablets
were the best of doing work though
Samsung didn't do a bad job especially
with multitasking that said I still
prefer my laptop I'm just more efficient
on it and then the closer these things
get it being good for work the worse
they are doing tablet II things I want
something that I can just keep on my lap
and isn't cramped and then something I
can lean back with and read and watch a
movie on which means I'm back to the
beginning I'm spending my days with my
laptop and the nights with my iPad